This is a re-broadcast of one of our favorite episodes of all time if you haven't heard it before, you're in for a real treat, even if you have heard it before, you should listen again because it is really great. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On any given day, there are a few different kinds of songs rattling around in my head. Some were just classics, like literal classics. And there were songs that are just in there that are my own favorite. Songs that have carved out a space in my brain because I listen to them over and over and over.
这是我们有史以来最受欢迎的节目之一的重播。如果你以前没听过，那你有福了；即使你听过，也应该再听一遍，因为它真的很棒。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。在任何一天，我的脑海里总会萦绕着几种不同的歌。有些是真正的经典，字面意义上的经典。还有一些歌是我个人的最爱，它们在我的大脑中占据了一席之地，因为我一遍又一遍地听它们。
I'm sorry, I'm sorry. That's the song solidarity by the band's scream. Oh, that song is so good. And then there's this other category of memorable songs, the ones that we all just kind of know. Songs that somehow, without anyone's permission, snuck their way into our collective unconscious and now are just lingering there for all eternity. These songs aren't necessarily good, but they usually have some undeniably catchy quality
抱歉，抱歉。那是乐队Scream的歌《Solidarity》。哦，那首歌太棒了。还有另一类令人难忘的歌曲，就是我们大家都耳熟能详的那种。这些歌不知怎么地，在未经任何人许可的情况下，潜入了我们的集体潜意识，现在在那里永恒地徘徊。这些歌不一定好听，但它们通常有一种不可否认的洗脑特质，
to them, a hook that worms its way into our brains and never leaves. Like this one. But I think there's one song in the last 25 years that exemplifies this phenomenon more than any other. It's a song that I think nearly every one of you will recognize. It is not my favorite. You did not ask for it, dear listener, but today's entire episode is devoted to who let the dogs out.
一种能钻进我们大脑并挥之不去的钩子。就像这一首。但我认为过去25年里有一首歌比任何其他歌曲都更能体现这种现象。我相信你们几乎每个人都能认出这首歌。它不是我的最爱。亲爱的听众，你并没有要求听它，但今天整集节目都献给《Who Let The Dogs Out》。
Don't go. I swear, it'll be good, because this is a story about how that song ended up stuck in all of our brains, and it's actually really complicated and it goes back decades and spans continents, and in the end, I think it tells us something important about inspiration and how creativity spreads, and about whether an idea can ever really belong to just one person. To tell the story, we have brought in the world's foremost expert on who let the dogs out. Yeah, it's an undisputed title. This is Ben Sisto. In about 10 years ago, Ben was reading the Wikipedia entry for the song, Who Let The Dogs
别走。我发誓，这会很有趣，因为这是一个关于这首歌是如何卡在我们所有人脑海里的故事。它其实非常复杂，可以追溯到几十年前，跨越了各大洲。最终，我认为它告诉了我们关于灵感、创造力如何传播，以及一个想法是否真的能只属于一个人的重要道理。为了讲述这个故事，我们请来了世界上关于《Who Let The Dogs Out》的头号专家。没错，这是一个无可争议的头衔。这是本·西斯托。大约10年前，本在阅读这首歌的维基百科条目时，
Out by the Bahamian. And I noticed this like missing citation. The Wikipedia entry said that the Bahamian didn't actually write the song, but a British hairdresser named Keith had heard it on a trip to Carnival in Chinatown, in Tobago, and that he passed it along to music producers. But it was all very vague. And that made Ben curious, so curious that he spent the next 10 years trying to figure out the answer to what seems like a pretty straightforward question.
由巴哈马人演唱。我注意到这里缺少一个引用。维基百科条目说，巴哈马人实际上并没有写这首歌，而是一位名叫基思的英国理发师在多巴哥唐人街参加狂欢节时听到的，然后他把它传给了音乐制作人。但这一切都很模糊。这让本很好奇，好奇到他花了接下来的10年时间试图弄清楚一个看起来相当简单的问题的答案。
Who wrote Who Let The Dogs Out? And I just kind of got this journalism bug, so I just kept asking people who let the dogs out. And here we are a decade later. Our story begins in the year 2000, but the release of that song by the Bob, then. Who Let The Dogs Out? I know exactly where I was the first time I heard this song.
谁写了《Who Let The Dogs Out》？我只是产生了一种新闻报道的冲动，所以我一直问别人是谁放出了狗。就这样，十年过去了。我们的故事始于2000年，当时巴哈马人发行了那首歌。谁放出了狗？我清楚地记得第一次听到这首歌时我在哪里。
I saw a game at Pac-Bow Park. It was what it was called then to see the Giants play. And before the game, the Bahamian came out, played this song. I'd never heard it before. Never heard of the Bahamian. It might have been already a hit, but it seemed like everyone already knew it. And even if you'd never heard it before, you kind of feel you know the song already. Like it has a kind of like,
我在太平洋贝尔公园看比赛。当时它叫这个名字，去看巨人队的比赛。比赛开始前，巴哈马人乐队出来表演了这首歌。我以前从未听过。也从未听说过巴哈马人乐队。它可能已经是一首热门歌曲了，但似乎每个人都已经知道了。即使你以前从未听过，你也会觉得你已经熟悉这首歌了。就像它有一种，
Jungian, Ertex kind of quality to it. So who are the Bahamas? So Bahamas are a really hard working, multi-generational band from the Bahamas. And they've been playing together in one form or another since the 70s. They started off as a group called High Voltage, sort of playing resorts around the islands. And they've always been known for this style called
荣格式的、原型般的特质。那么巴哈马人是谁呢？巴哈马人是一支来自巴哈马的非常勤奋、多代同堂的乐队。自70年代以来，他们以各种形式在一起演奏。他们最初是一个叫“高压”的组合，在岛上的度假村表演。他们一直以一种名为
Junkanew, and that's the music associated with a street parade by the same name. You can think big bright costumes, hundreds of steel drums, and cowbells, and goat skin drums, just like a big party. This is kind of like the scene that Baha Menn are part of. You don't have to worry, or even say a story when you hear this joke can do. They were signed by a young Ann Argy, Steve Greenberg, and he stayed with them across multiple labels and break even releases, and Steve actually ends up being the guy who convinces them
“Junkanoo”的风格而闻名，这是与同名街头游行相关的音乐。你可以想象一下明亮的大服装、数百个钢鼓、牛铃和羊皮鼓，就像一场盛大的派对。这就是巴哈马人所处的场景。当你听到这种Junkanoo音乐时，你不需要担心，甚至不需要讲故事。他们被年轻的A&R史蒂夫·格林伯格签下，他陪伴他们跨越了多个厂牌和唱片发行，而史蒂夫实际上最终成为了说服他们
to record who let the dogs out. The song had a really amazing hook. And I say, one of these days I'm going to figure out how to do this, you know? Do this song right, because there's something here. And I just never forgot about the song. I knew that the Bahamian were the people who I wanted to record the song. They just made sense to me. And in fact, I used to keep a diary and I wrote in my diary,
录制《Who Let The Dogs Out》的人。这首歌有一个非常棒的钩子。我说，总有一天我要弄清楚怎么做这首歌，你知道吗？把这首歌做好，因为这里面有些东西。我从未忘记过这首歌。我知道巴哈马人是我想要录制这首歌的人。他们对我来说就是最合适的。事实上，我过去常写日记，我在日记里写道，
I'm going to record that song, who let the dogs out with the Bahamen and have a big hit all over the world. I'm certain. This sounds kind of crazy on retrospect, but Bahamen were like, no thanks. The song was already a hit in that area and they just didn't think it would be a good look to cover something everybody already knew. I didn't want to do the song. That's why I have to give Steve credit. I'm not gonna ask you to do anything else, just one song and hey, as a Steve conversation is finished, we will do the song. I'm extremely happy that we did.
我要和巴哈马人一起录制那首《Who Let The Dogs Out》，并让它在全世界大火。我确信。回想起来这听起来有点疯狂，但巴哈马人当时说，不，谢谢。这首歌在那个地区已经很红了，他们觉得翻唱一首大家都已经知道的歌看起来不太好。我不想做这首歌。这就是为什么我必须给史蒂夫记上一功。我不会要求你们做任何其他事情，就这一首歌，嘿，史蒂夫的谈话结束了，我们会做这首歌。我非常高兴我们做了。
So why did their producer Steve care so much about the song? I think Steve's just one of these guys who knows a hit when he hears it. Steve's also given for better or worse the world. He's given the world acts like Hanson. And if there's a song that's going to like play well and stadiums and Disney. Yeah, he just knows. So you said the song was already hitting the Bahamas. Is that where he heard it originally, Steve? Yeah, so Steve heard the song via Keith Wainwright, who's like my original Wikipedia mystery guy. And Steve Greenberg kind of instantly knew that there was like something special about the hook
那么为什么他们的制作人史蒂夫如此在意这首歌呢？我认为史蒂夫只是那种一听到热门歌曲就知道的人。史蒂夫也给世界带来了像Hanson这样的艺人，无论好坏。如果有哪首歌能在体育场和迪士尼里大受欢迎，是的，他就是知道。所以你说这首歌在巴哈马已经很红了。那是他最初听到它的地方吗，史蒂夫？是的，史蒂夫是通过基思·温赖特听到这首歌的，他就是我最初的维基百科神秘人物。史蒂夫·格林伯格几乎立刻就知道这个钩子有什么特别之处，
and that kind of led to him deciding to pitch it to Baham. Yeah. So Steve, here's the song. Likes this song. Well, it doesn't really like the song, but like the hook of the song. So who wrote the hook? To find that out, it's the late 90s.
这促使他决定向巴哈马人推销它。是的。所以史蒂夫听到了这首歌。喜欢这首歌。嗯，其实他并不是真的喜欢这首歌，而是喜欢这首歌的钩子。那么是谁写的这个钩子呢？为了找到答案，时间回到了90年代末。
So Steve went and as the one did in the late 90s, asked Jeves to the website and said, Jeves, who let the dogs out. And this led Steve to a message board where people were discussing their vacations and music played at Carnival. And this is where Steve first learns that this track is cut by a guy named Anselm Douglas.
所以史蒂夫去了，像90年代末的人一样，问Ask Jeeves网站，说，Jeeves，谁放出了狗。这把史蒂夫带到了一个留言板，人们在那里讨论他们的假期和狂欢节上播放的音乐。在这里，史蒂夫第一次了解到这首歌是由一个叫安塞尔姆·道格拉斯的人创作的。
I'm still amazed that after 20 years, it's still out there and playing a new kid's, a new generation is growing up on it. If you don't know the song, who let it go so that you will living under a rock. Think about it. What did a song you know been out there for 20 years and kids every child knows it?
我仍然很惊讶，20年后，它仍然在那里播放，新一代的孩子们在它伴随下成长。如果你不知道《Who Let The Dogs Out》，那你真是与世隔绝了。想想看，有什么歌你知道已经存在了20年，而且每个孩子都知道它？
So Douglass, it was actually already a known name in the Bahamas music scene. And he wanted to use his platform to write kind of a feminist anthem, like a song that could be this rallying cry for women who are fed up with like the dogs, men behaving poorly on the dance floor. So do you want to, how we can take a listen? Yeah, to his B.I.O? And everybody's having a ball. Yeah, buddy, B.I.O. Until I'm under satin' in calling.
所以道格拉斯，他实际上已经是巴哈马音乐界的一个知名名字了。他想利用他的平台写一首女权主义赞歌，一首能成为那些受够了舞池里表现糟糕的“狗”（男人）的女性的集结号。你想听听吗？是的，听听他的B.I.O？每个人都在狂欢。是的，伙计，B.I.O。直到我坐在缎子上呼唤。
Oh, yeah, you B.I.O. Then I'm going to be spawn to D.Col. I have a man shout out, Who let the dogs out? Who, who, who, who, who, Let the dogs out? Who, who, who, who, who, That is the song.
哦，是的，你B.I.O。然后我要去D.Col。我有一个男人大喊，谁放出了狗？谁，谁，谁，谁，谁，放出了狗？谁，谁，谁，谁，谁，这就是那首歌。
That's it. That's it. Wow. I mean, that seems very clear. So Anselm Douglas wrote that hook and that's the thing we think of when we think of this song, we let the dogs out. Although I love the arrangement, actually. Yeah, I do too.
就是这样。就是这样。哇。我的意思是，这看起来非常清楚。所以安塞尔姆·道格拉斯写了那个钩子，这就是我们想到这首歌时想到的东西，我们放出了狗。虽然我其实很喜欢这个编曲。是的，我也喜欢。
And, you know, Douglas is obviously more in the Soca, Calipso tradition and it's more like a take off your shirt, take off your towel, whip it at a high BPM. And the Baja Man is just like, Americanized hip hop influence. But the Bahamas version retains this like, junk-a-new undertone, which was really important for us crossover movements for the genre. So when it comes to the question, who let the dogs out? The answer is, Anselam Douglas. Not quite.
而且，你知道，道格拉斯显然更多地处于Soca、Calypso传统中，更像是脱掉你的衬衫，脱掉你的毛巾，以高BPM挥舞它。而巴哈马人的版本更像是美国化的嘻哈影响。但巴哈马人的版本保留了这种Junkanoo的基调，这对该流派的跨界运动非常重要。所以当谈到“谁放出了狗”这个问题时，答案是，安塞尔姆·道格拉斯。不完全是。
Douglas wrote Doggy, but it really wasn't like his idea alone. I never tool anyone. Hey, I came up with the phrase, never did, because I didn't. You know, I know that my brother-in-law was the one who said, Hey, you've got to do this song. You've got to do this song. Oh, that's all right. Now we'll do it.
道格拉斯写了《Doggy》，但这真的不仅仅是他一个人的主意。我从来没告诉过任何人，嘿，我想出了这个短语，从来没有，因为我没有。你知道，我知道是我姐夫说，嘿，你得做这首歌。你得做这首歌。哦，那好吧。现在我们要做了。
You know, so he was the one who encouraged me to do it. So I gave him that credit because he was the one who said, do this song. So Douglas' former brother-in-law was the host of this DJ Mix Show, Rec Shop Radio out of Toronto. And two of that shows producers were these guys, Patrick Stephenson and LaRoy Williams, who, you know, they're like writing promos and jingles for it. And one of those jingles contained the phrase, who let the dogs out, followed
你知道，所以是他鼓励我做的。所以我把功劳归给他，因为是他说，做这首歌。所以道格拉斯的前姐夫是多伦多Rec Shop Radio的DJ混音节目的主持人。该节目的两名制作人是帕特里克·斯蒂芬森和拉罗伊·威廉姆斯，你知道，他们负责写宣传片和广告歌。其中一首广告歌包含了“谁放出了狗”这个短语，后面跟着
by the sound of dogs barking and this is late 95 early 96. And the front of the office I used to go who let the dogs out and recently I then he go and I go who let the dogs out of here the way I was going and then we brought that and patchy was like put that all together that's how that vibration came out. It was very hard to track these guys down, but after years of begging and calling and DMing, they eventually produced these original recordings. Yeah, so that's really it. That's like the chorus right there. That's it. Wow. Yeah, I mean, that's the hook. But this part kind of gets a little fuzzy because we'll want it to 20 years ago, but people involved have different accounts. The long short is that Stephenson and Williams,
狗叫声，这是95年底96年初的事。办公室前面我常说谁放出了狗，最近我然后他去，我说谁放出了狗，我听到了我走的方式，然后我们带来了那个，帕奇说把这些放在一起，这就是那种震动产生的方式。追踪这些人非常困难，但在多年的恳求、打电话和私信之后，他们最终拿出了这些原始录音。是的，这真的是它。这就是副歌。就是这样。哇。是的，我的意思是，这就是钩子。但这一部分有点模糊，因为那是20年前的事了，但相关人员有不同的说法。长话短说，斯蒂芬森和威廉姆斯，
kind of on a handshake agreement, told Douglas, like, okay, like, use this, write a song, go down to Carnival, but they didn't think it was gonna become a big hit, and they didn't really know much about like protecting publishing rights at the time. We were so in love with doing the music and being creative, but we were passionate about creating
在一种握手协议下，告诉道格拉斯，好吧，用这个，写首歌，去参加狂欢节，但他们没想到它会成为大热门，而且他们当时对保护出版权了解不多。我们太热爱做音乐和发挥创造力了，但我们热衷于创作，
and not taking care of the business and the business bit us in the end. Wow. So they like sort of handshake deal, allowed Anselm Douglas to make this carnival song of who let the dogs out called Doggy. And then it's the one who gets licensed to the Bahamian to make who let the dogs out. So did Steffensen and Williams know anything about the licensing to the Bahamian? Not until they heard it on the radio.
而没有处理商业事务，最终商业反噬了我们。哇。所以他们那种握手协议，允许安塞尔姆·道格拉斯制作了这首名为《Doggy》的狂欢节歌曲《Who Let The Dogs Out》。然后它被授权给巴哈马人制作了《Who Let The Dogs Out》。那么斯蒂芬森和威廉姆斯知道授权给巴哈马人的事吗？直到他们在收音机里听到它之前都不知道。
Oh, that's rough. Yeah, I mean, for a song so happy, it's a very dark moment. Oh my God, oh my God. I'm going to a Jamaican restaurant and hearing this record that we did, they can leave the hook and I'm hearing it on the radio. Oh yeah, oh my God. I'm going to a Jamaican restaurant and hearing this record that we did, they can leave the hook and I'm hearing it on the radio. Oh yeah, we wrote that and other people
哦，那太糟糕了。是的，我的意思是，对于一首如此快乐的歌来说，这是一个非常黑暗的时刻。天哪，天哪。我去一家牙买加餐馆，听到我们做的这张唱片，他们可以留下钩子，而我在收音机里听到它。哦，是的，天哪。我去一家牙买加餐馆，听到我们做的这张唱片，他们可以留下钩子，而我在收音机里听到它。哦，是的，我们写了那个，而其他人
are making so much money off this thing. That was just like, yeah, it was hard after you found out that someone else is making money off your idea. So there's no official ruling, but Douglas signs in Affidavid, asserting that Stephenson and Williams were the original authors of the hook, that his work was based on, that gives Douglas the rights to move forward with his own version
正靠这个赚这么多钱。那真是，是的，在发现别人靠你的想法赚钱后，这很难受。所以没有官方裁决，但道格拉斯签署了一份宣誓书，断言斯蒂芬森和威廉姆斯是该钩子的原始作者，他的作品是基于此的，这给了道格拉斯继续他自己版本和授权的权利。
and licensing. Okay, so let me try to get this all straight. So when it comes to who let the dogs out, there's Steve and the Bahamas, who made the super popular version that most people know. who made the super popular version that most people know. There's Anselam Douglas, who made the version from the Bahamas called Doggy that was directly covered and licensed by the Bahammen. And then there's these DJs who had this brilliant innovation of bearing a rhetorical question with the dogs barking. And so that's incredibly complicated,
好吧，让我试着把这一切理清楚。所以当谈到《Who Let The Dogs Out》时，有史蒂夫和巴哈马人，他们制作了大多数人都知道的超级流行版本。有安塞尔姆·道格拉斯，他制作了来自巴哈马的名为《Doggy》的版本，该版本被巴哈马人直接翻唱和授权。然后还有这些DJ，他们有将反问句与狗叫声结合的绝妙创新。所以这是一组令人难以置信的复杂的人、版本、权利和权利持有人，人们在争斗，这真是令人震惊。
set of people and versions and rights and rights holders and people fighting, it's just kind of stunning. Well, actually, there's more. So what is that? So what is that? That is a remix of a song called Yura Dog, which is by a group called 20 Fingers featuring the singer Gillette, and that came out in 94. It was a follow-up single to their global kind of mega hit short dick man. Do you remember that song?
好吧，其实还有更多。那是什么？那是什么？那是名为《You're A Dog》的歌曲的混音版，由一个叫20 Fingers的组合演唱，歌手是吉列，那是在94年发行的。它是他们全球大热单曲《Short Dick Man》的后续单曲。你还记得那首歌吗？
No, it doesn't. It doesn't leave immediately to mind. Well, I mean, as I kind of just implied, short dick man was in fact huge and this big, big global hit and yeah, people were paying attention to these artists and stuff coming out of the Chicago scene. They were sort of like Douglas. They wanted a way to like make a fun record that hit back against some of the like misogyny that was going on in dance music at the time. Many more who is part of the 20 fingers writing and production team
不，不记得。它不会立刻浮现在脑海中。好吧，我的意思是，正如我刚才暗示的那样，那首歌确实非常火，是全球大热单曲，是的，人们都在关注这些艺人和来自芝加哥场景的东西。他们有点像道格拉斯。他们想要一种方式来制作一张有趣的唱片，反击当时舞曲中存在的一些厌女症。曼尼·莫尔是20 Fingers写作和制作团队的一员，
just felt very frustrated by all that. So that's kind of where your dog comes from. So this one was released in 1994. Does that mean that they are like the legally the authors of the song who let the dogs out? So here we kind of need to maybe shift gears and talk about copyright for a sec. Okay. When so when you're considering a copyright infringement claim, there's two areas you really want to focus on. And their access and similarity, the latter similarity is pretty straightforward. It's like, do these things look or sound the same, but even if two things seem very similar,
对这一切感到非常沮丧。所以这就是《You're A Dog》的由来。所以这一首是在1994年发行的。这是否意味着他们在法律上是《Who Let The Dogs Out》这首歌的作者？所以在这里我们需要换个档位，谈谈版权。好的。当你考虑版权侵权索赔时，有两个领域你真的需要关注。接触和相似性，后者相似性相当直接。就像，这些东西看起来或听起来一样吗，但即使两件事看起来非常相似，
which of course is subjective, the courts will recognize there's a finite number of ways to arrange notes and words. So you also have to consider this concept of access, which, in short, means was the alleged infringer aware of the plaintiffs' work. Like, what's the line between copying and coincidence? Okay. And so did the Canadian DJs... Did they hear this song by Gillette? Stephenson and Williams claimed to have never heard of a song or anything about 20 fingers. Based on Gillette's charting and billboard and stuff, I find that a little tough to believe,
当然这是主观的，法院会承认排列音符和单词的方法是有限的。所以你还必须考虑这个“接触”的概念，简而言之，这意味着被指控的侵权者是否知道原告的作品。就像，抄袭和巧合之间的界限在哪里？好的。那么加拿大DJ们……他们听过吉列的那首歌吗？斯蒂芬森和威廉姆斯声称从未听说过那首歌或关于20 Fingers的任何事情。基于吉列的排行榜和公告牌等情况，我觉得这有点难以置信，
but I have to take them at their word. And so legally, does Gillette and 20 fingers have a case that their copyright had been infringed? I think they did, but at the time their label didn't want to pursue it. There's a joke about copyright being the right to be held up in court until your bankrupt. If you're like an indie label or something like that, you might not have the resources and assets to sue a major label who can just kind of treat their legal expenses the same way one might like marketing costs you know it's kind of all the same pot as long as you have like a net positive result.
但我必须相信他们的话。那么在法律上，吉列和20 Fingers是否有理由认为他们的版权受到了侵犯？我认为他们有，但当时他们的厂牌不想追究。有一个关于版权的笑话，说版权就是被拖在法庭上直到你破产的权利。如果你是一个独立厂牌之类的，你可能没有资源和资产去起诉一个大厂牌，他们可以把法律费用当作营销成本来处理，你知道，只要你有净正结果，这都是一回事。
Okay that makes sense. So I guess the DJs are the ones with the legal claim to the song because they weren't challenged by 20 fingers but 20 fingers can say that they are the original authors of the song. Not so fast for a minute. Here's Kansai that they are the original authors of the song. Not so fast, Brumant. That's one of these people. This is Miami Boom Productions of Jacksonville, Florida with their song Who Let The Dogs Out, which was written and recorded in 1992. Goodness.
好的，这说得通。所以我猜DJ们是这首歌的合法权利人，因为他们没有受到20 Fingers的挑战，但20 Fingers可以说他们是这首歌的原始作者。别急，布鲁曼特。这是其中之一。这是佛罗里达州杰克逊维尔的Miami Boom Productions，他们的歌曲《Who Let The Dogs Out》是在1992年创作和录制的。天哪。
This duo is Brett Hammock and Joe Gonzalez. They're stage names at the time, Be Nasty and Miami J, who are basically just like cool teenagers and they want to write, produce, and perform Miami-based music, that was it. That was everything to them. I actually had someone call me and they're like, hey, I heard you and Joe's song on the radio, and I was like, no, you didn't. And you're like, oh, yeah, I swear to you, who let the dogs out?
这对组合是布雷特·哈莫克和乔·冈萨雷斯。他们当时的艺名是Be Nasty和Miami J，他们基本上只是酷酷的青少年，他们想写、制作和表演迈阿密风格的音乐，就是这样。这对他们来说就是一切。我实际上有人打电话给我，他们说，嘿，我在收音机里听到了你和乔的歌，我说，不，你没有。你说，哦，是的，我向你发誓，谁放出了狗？
I just heard it on the radio. We flipped it on and I'm just thinking somebody ripped off our track. Wow. So this is another set of people completely blindsided by hearing the Bahamans who let the dogs out on the radio. Completely. There's actually this kind of amazing story
我刚在收音机里听到。我们打开它，我心想有人剽窃了我们的曲目。哇。所以这是另一群完全被在收音机里听到巴哈马人的《Who Let The Dogs Out》而感到震惊的人。完全震惊。其实有一个非常神奇的故事，
of where they came up with the hook. So these guys are, they're driving around Florida and their parents, Chevy Astro Van, they've taken the back seats out to make room for extra speakers, and they're blasting this album, Kings of Base, by Base Patrol. On that album, there's a song called Demand Scientist, and very, very low in the mix. Like you can barely hear it if you're not looking for it. There is a sample, and Bret and Joe didn't know what it said.
关于他们是怎么想出这个钩子的。所以这些人，他们开着父母的雪佛兰Astro面包车在佛罗里达兜风，他们拆掉了后座以腾出空间放额外的扬声器，他们正在播放Base Patrol的专辑《Kings of Base》。在那张专辑里，有一首歌叫《Demand Scientist》，在混音中非常非常低。就像如果你不注意听，你几乎听不到它。有一个采样，布雷特和乔不知道它说了什么。
They're making up lyrics, at some point they just said Who let the dogs out and kind of stuck? I just started throwing my arms there. Oh I'm driving he didn't take me as mocking him. He started doing it too So we're jumping around hopping around singing this song we just made up and I looked at him I said, you know, it's a pretty good hook. That sample is actually saying, who's rocking this dog's house? And it comes from pump up the party by Hassan.
他们编造了歌词，在某个时刻他们只是说“谁放出了狗”，然后就卡住了？我开始把手臂扔在那里。哦，我开车时他没把我当成在嘲笑他。他也开始那样做了。所以我们跳来跳去，蹦来蹦去，唱着我们刚编出来的这首歌，我看着他说，你知道，这是一个相当不错的钩子。那个采样实际上是在说，“谁在摇晃这只狗的房子？”它来自Hassan的《Pump Up The Party》。
We should take a listen to this one. It's not exactly the same. I would argue the Miami boom stuff is transformative enough to be considered a new work, but you can really hear the seeds of it. Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah!
我们应该听听这一首。它不完全一样。我会说Miami Boom的东西足够具有变革性，可以被视为一部新作品，但你真的可以听到它的种子。Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah!
Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah!
Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! So this is the thing that Miami Boom heard and turned it into their version of who let the dogs out. Correct. You can see how it's a progenitor, but it does seem like the leap between the two versions is greater than this one, as opposed to a lot of the other ones that we've heard today. I would say this is more an instance of influence than copying. Right. Okay, so Miami Boom wrote this song in 1992.
Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! Boozahiddaah! 所以这就是Miami Boom听到的东西，并把它变成了他们的《Who Let The Dogs Out》版本。正确。你可以看出它是祖先，但看起来两者之间的跨度比这个版本要大，而不是像我们今天听到的其他许多版本那样。我会说这更多是影响而不是抄袭的例子。对。好的，所以Miami Boom在1992年写了这首歌。
And was it released? Did other people hear it? Very few, and I only became aware of it because they had posted it to YouTube, which isn't really great for copyright dating purposes, because it's like, who knows when it was recorded. But after kind of earning their trust over a couple of years and stuff, they eventually produced a bunch of stuff like old flyers and one of the best things they produced with these floppy disks that had the original vocals and samples from the recording session.
它发行了吗？其他人听到了吗？很少，我只是因为他们把它发布到YouTube上才意识到这一点，这对版权日期来说并不是很好，因为谁知道它是什么时候录制的。但在赢得他们的信任几年后，他们最终拿出了一堆东西，比如旧传单，他们拿出的最好的东西之一是这些软盘，里面有录音过程中的原始人声和采样。
In that box of floppy, there was even the original receipt from the Kmart where they bought them in Florida. So that was like one way of dating it. Then I took those disks to a data preservation company in the UK called Cryoflux, who helped me identify the hardware that would have been used. And then I found a DJ who had this piece of hardware and we opened them up, all the samples were there. Who let the dogs out?
在那盒软盘里，甚至还有他们在佛罗里达购买它们时的原始收据。所以这是一种确定日期的方法。然后我把那些磁盘带到了英国一家名为Cryoflux的数据保存公司，他们帮我确定了可能使用的硬件。然后我找到了一个拥有这件硬件的DJ，我们打开了它们，所有的采样都在那里。谁放出了狗？
Who do you let the days out? Who let the dogs out? And this DJ and producer, his name is Mishna, he's also from Florida, knows a lot about Miami-Base, and he kind of verified for me, there was no way that this was fake. Wow. The Root!
谁放出了狗？谁放出了狗？这位DJ兼制作人，他的名字叫Mishna，他也来自佛罗里达，对迈阿密贝斯音乐了解很多，他为我验证了，这不可能是假的。哇。根源！
The Root! The Root! First, we miss the Mishna fire! fake. Wow. Once you determine the veracity of their song that it was out there in the world, does Miami boom also feel like they're owed something like in terms of the copyright of who let the dogs out? They definitely do, and I think they also want credit given to their studio engineer, her name was Mama Do. When I think about the times making this music, it was phenomenal. It was the best times of my life. The bottom line is I know where we believe it came from. There's three names
根源！根源！首先，我们错过了Mishna火！假的。哇。一旦你确定了他们歌曲的真实性，即它确实存在于世界上，Miami Boom是否也觉得他们应该得到什么，比如在《Who Let The Dogs Out》的版权方面？他们绝对觉得，而且我认为他们也希望给他们的录音室工程师记上一功，她的名字叫Mama Do。当我想到制作这些音乐的时光时，那真是太棒了。那是我一生中最美好的时光。底线是我知道我们相信它来自哪里。有三个名字
missing from that song and they're sitting right here. We should own that song. Yeah. We should own that song. Yeah. The story is fun because the song is kind of funny and light and it's a carnival song. But there's a real sadness to this. Yeah, it's difficult as an artist to think about people who aren't given proper attribution. You know, like being cut out of a financial deal is one thing, but to be unknown when your song is known globally, I think, hurts. Yeah.
从那首歌中消失了，它们就在这里。我们应该拥有那首歌。是的。我们应该拥有那首歌。是的。这个故事很有趣，因为这首歌有点滑稽和轻快，这是一首狂欢节歌曲。但这里面有一种真正的悲伤。是的，作为一名艺术家，想到那些没有得到适当归属的人是很困难的。你知道，被排除在财务交易之外是一回事，但当你的歌在全球范围内广为人知时，你却默默无闻，我认为这很伤人。是的。
Okay, so I feel like I need to recap here a little bit. So let's go through all the versions. So first, here's the Bahamian playing the version that we all know. Who let the dogs out? Who let the dogs out? Which they got from Anselm Douglas in the Bahamas. Which he got from the Canadian radio DJs in the mid 90s. But before them Gillette and 20 Fingers wrote this version in Chicago in 1994. Before that, Miami Boom wrote this in 1922. Yeah, Roman, I hate to keep doing this to you, but there is more.
好的，我觉得我需要在这里总结一下。所以让我们过一遍所有的版本。首先，这是巴哈马人演奏我们大家都知道的版本。谁放出了狗？谁放出了狗？他们从巴哈马的安塞尔姆·道格拉斯那里得到了它。他从90年代中期的加拿大电台DJ那里得到了它。但在他们之前，吉列和20 Fingers在1994年于芝加哥写了这个版本。在此之前，Miami Boom在1992年写了这个。是的，罗曼，我不想一直这样对你，但还有更多。
So what is that? Yeah. After I started doing some research and getting a little pressed, this guy, John Michael Davis from Duwajak, Michigan, learned about what I was doing and got in touch. He told me this story that starts in 1990 in Duwajak. Then it was sort of like a down and out place. I had this nickname, the dog patch, and the town really needed like something to rally around. So John tells me this like Rudy, like tale of high school football, where there's like
那是什么？是的。在我开始做一些研究并受到一点压力后，这个来自密歇根州杜瓦贾克的家伙，约翰·迈克尔·戴维斯，了解了我在做什么并联系了我。他告诉我这个故事始于1990年的杜瓦贾克。当时它有点像一个落魄的地方。我有一个绰号，狗补丁，镇上真的需要一些东西来团结起来。所以约翰告诉我这个像《鲁迪》一样的故事，关于高中橄榄球，那里有
a Hail Mary pass and he just starts chanting, ooh, ooh, let the dogs out. And then the whole stadium starts chanting it. And then yeah, it just happens. I should profess and say, that's how he chanting it. And then, yeah, it just happens. I should preface and say, that's how he remembers it. Other people from this football team don't remember it that way. Some people told me a guy named Keith the funky bus driver came up with it. It's kind of a mystery, but what's important is this team blew up. They won the state champion and this chant was their motto.
一个万福玛丽传球，他只是开始高呼，噢，噢，放出了狗。然后整个体育场开始高呼它。然后是的，它就发生了。我应该先说一下，这就是他记忆中的方式。这个橄榄球队的其他成员不记得是那样了。有些人告诉我一个叫基思的放克公交车司机想出了它。这有点神秘，但重要的是这个团队爆发了。他们赢得了州冠军，这个口号是他们的座右铭。
So, as part of the research, we visited Duajak, and just like locals were like, oh, what are you guys doing here? Oh, we're researching who let the dogs out, and people just start giving us VHS tapes and like old silk screens, and there's just all this stuff there with who let the dogs out on it from 1990.
所以，作为研究的一部分，我们访问了杜瓦贾克，当地人就像，哦，你们在这里做什么？哦，我们在研究谁放出了狗，人们就开始给我们VHS录像带和旧丝网印刷品，那里到处都是1990年关于谁放出了狗的东西。
This team's coach was named Bernard Thomas, and he was so beloved, they called him St. Bernard, his players were like his dogs, and it just made sense. So is the assertion that they're making? Is that this football chant traveled down to Miami to inspire Miami boom. I think they're not sure where it traveled to next or how, but get this. Joe from Miami boom
这个队的教练叫伯纳德·托马斯，他深受爱戴，他们叫他圣伯纳德，他的球员就像他的狗，这很有道理。所以他们提出的主张是？这个橄榄球口号传到了迈阿密，启发了Miami Boom吗？我想他们不确定它接下来传到了哪里或怎么传的，但听着。来自Miami Boom的乔
is originally from Michigan until he was like eight years old or something. So I plotted this Google map of all the places the chant appeared in Michigan after the Duodjak Sheftens had this great victory year. In that map formed a near perfect circle around Joe's hometown. So I was like, are you kidding me? So it just looked so clean. So I got in touch with Joe and he verified for me
最初来自密歇根，直到他八岁左右。所以我绘制了这张谷歌地图，显示了杜瓦贾克谢夫顿队获得伟大的胜利年后，口号在密歇根州出现的所有地方。那张地图在乔的家乡周围形成了一个近乎完美的圆圈。所以我当时想，你在开玩笑吗？所以它看起来太干净了。所以我联系了乔，他为我验证了
that he was there that summer visiting family But he says he's got absolutely no memory of hearing the chat But also when I pressed him with the evidence he wasn't like overly defensive about it song you know call to let the dogs out what I can say is in 1992 I heard a song call to let the dogs out if you want to hear it from YouTube. Yeah well what we know is the other song I can ever say. So as it turns out who let the dogs out, let the dogs out, let the some dogs loose. These are all phrases that actually pop up here and there in regionals high school sports, right, long before someone recorded a song, before Stevie B. So I'm scouring like all these old newspaper archives. The earliest I've been able to find was from 1986, the Austin Reagan High School in Austin, my. Yeah, that's from a pep rally.
他那个夏天确实在那里探亲，但他声称他完全不记得听到过这个口号。但当我用证据逼问他时，他并没有表现得过于防御。歌，你知道，呼吁放出狗，我能说的是在1992年我听到了一首叫放出狗的歌，如果你想从YouTube上听的话。是的，好吧，我们知道的是我能说的另一首歌。所以事实证明，谁放出了狗，放出了狗，放出了一些狗。这些都是在地区高中体育运动中不时出现的短语，对吧，远在有人录制歌曲之前，在史蒂夫·B之前。所以我正在搜寻所有这些旧报纸档案。我能找到的最早的是1986年的，奥斯汀的里根高中，奥斯汀，我的。是的，那是来自一场动员大会。
And it's just a weird, like, couple of seconds embedded in this much longer video, chronicling the football team. It's been on YouTube this whole time. And what year is that? 1986. I mean, that sounds more like the last version, you know, like the final version than even some of the ones in between. Roman, it's a wild ride. Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness. So is this, and we finally reached the bedrock of who let the dogs out? Do we actually know who let the dogs out at this point?
它只是嵌入在这个更长的视频中的奇怪的几秒钟，记录了橄榄球队。它一直都在YouTube上。那是哪一年？1986年。我的意思是，这听起来比中间的一些版本更像最后一个版本，你知道，就像最终版本。罗曼，这是一次疯狂的旅程。天哪。天哪。所以这是我们终于到达了《Who Let The Dogs Out》的基石了吗？我们现在真的知道是谁放出了狗吗？
Well, this is as far back as I can go. The title of the Bahamian song doesn't have a question mark in it, and after looking into it all this time, I just have to accept that maybe it's not a question. It's probably unanswerable. I mean, when you started this, did you think it would be this hard to determine who wrote a single song? No way. I think if I had known I would not have done this. But you know, it is a nice surprise and there's been a lot of nice surprises along the way. I got to meet all these cool people and producers. Maybe I would have done it again.
嗯，这是我能追溯到的最远的地方。巴哈马人歌曲的标题里没有问号，在研究了这么久之后，我不得不接受也许它不是一个问题。它可能是无法回答的。我的意思是，当你开始做这个的时候，你认为确定谁写了一首歌会这么难吗？绝不可能。我想如果我知道的话，我就不会这么做了。但你知道，这是一个不错的惊喜，一路上有很多不错的惊喜。我认识了所有这些很酷的人和制作人。也许我会再做一次。
Yeah. There are all these sort of like ways in which people borrow and they take in information. They just, it comes process in their brains. They maybe they spit it out as an homage or maybe they don't know where it comes from. I mean, do you think about like how a song is passed between different people, like, are some of them lined, or are none of them lined? I mean, like, where do you sort of stand in everyone's story in this story? I don't think anybody in this story is lying. And I actually think people have been pretty forthcoming and open to the notion that you can hear something
是的。人们借用和吸收信息的方式有各种各样。他们只是，它在他们的大脑中处理。他们也许把它作为一种致敬吐出来，或者也许他们不知道它来自哪里。我的意思是，你是否考虑过一首歌是如何在不同人之间传递的，比如，他们中有人在撒谎吗，还是都没有撒谎？我的意思是，在这个故事中，你站在每个人的故事的什么位置？我不认为这个故事里的任何人是在撒谎。而且我实际上认为人们一直相当坦率，并对你可以听到某样东西并将其潜意识地留在那里直到它准备好出来这一概念持开放态度。我认为我们对自己讲述的关于艺术的一大神话是它是由个人创造的，而那个神话正是艺术市场所支撑的东西。我的意思是，根据我自己的经验，我生动地记得
and it's just in there subconsciously until it's ready to come out. I think one of the big myths we tell ourselves about art is that it's made by individuals and that myth is sort of what the art market is like propped up on. I mean, from my own experience, I vividly remember
20岁在艺术学校的时候。我有一个想法，比如，木工课做一个盒子，盒子里会有一个录音带，里面包含盒子被制作时的声音，就像年轻的观念白日梦之类的。这曾是我的想法，直到多年后，我了解到罗伯特·莫里斯在1961年创作了一件名为《带有自身制作声音的盒子》的作品。所以就像，我不知道，我是从他那里得到的想法吗？是巧合吗？是抄袭吗？就像，我无法告诉你。
of being 20 at art school. I had this idea to like, you know, wood shop class to make a box and the box was going to have an audio tape that contained the sound of the box being made, just like youthful conceptual daydream or whatever. And this was my idea until like years later, I learned that Robert Morris created a work in 1961 called Bucks with the Sound of its Own Making. So it's like, I don't know, did I get the idea from him? Was it coincidence? Was it copying? Like, I just can't tell you.
我认为这就是关于狗的所有东西很酷的地方，它只是关于艺术和生活的本质。我认为所有这些想法都适用于有史以来创作的每一件创意作品。好吧，那太酷了。好吧，我真的很感谢你带我们踏上这段旅程。而且，你知道，也许我们永远不会知道谁放出了狗的答案。但这个问题仍然值得一问。好吧，谢谢你邀请我。
And I think that's what's cool about all the dog stuff is like, it's just about the very nature of art and life. And I think that all these ideas apply to like every piece of creative work ever made. Well, that's so cool. Well, I really appreciate you taking us on this journey. And, you know, maybe we'll never know the answer to who let the dogs out. But the question is still worth asking. Well, thanks for having me.
每当人们想听我谈论这个时，我都感到惊讶。但是的，这很有趣。谢谢。得知《Who Let The Dogs Out》实际上没有问号，我当然感到惊讶，但语法上是问题但实际上并没有写成问题的标题出奇地常见。更多内容将在之后揭晓。所以我现在和克里斯·佩鲁贝在录音室里，你其实在城里。是的。我在加利福尼亚州奥克兰。那太棒了。很高兴你在这里。很高兴来到这里。你帮我们整理了这集关于《Who Let The Dogs Out》的节目。其中一件事是
I'm surprised anytime people want to hear me talk about this. But yeah, it was a lot of fun. Thank you. It certainly surprised me to learn that who let the dogs out doesn't actually have a question mark, but titles that are grammatically questions without actually being written as questions are surprisingly common. More on that after this. So I'm in the studio with Chris Perube and you're actually in town. I am. I'm in Oakland, California. That's amazing. It's so good to have you here. It's great to be here. And you helped us put together this episode on who let the dogs out. And one of the things that is
在播客中很难传达的非凡之处在于，标题《Who Let The Dogs Out》有一种怪癖。是的。那就是，它不是一个问题。它不以问题结束。《Who Let The Dogs Out》只是它的结尾。结尾没有问号。是的，这是一个事实陈述，这真的很奇怪。实际上，当本谈论问号时，它让我想起了一年前发生的事情。当时我和我的朋友莉兹在一起，她是一位电影制片人。我们经常一起看电影。她说，嘿，你看过《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》吗？我小时候试着看过。
kind of remarkable that is hard to convey in a podcast is that there is a kind of quirk to the title who let the dogs out. Yes. And that is, is that it isn't a question. It doesn't end in a question. Who let the dogs out is just the end of it. There's no question mark at the end of it. Yeah, it's a statement of fact, which is really strange. And actually it reminded me when Ben was talking about the question mark. It reminded me of something that happened to be a year ago. So I was hanging out with my friend Liz, who's a movie producer. We watch a lot of movies together. And she's like, hey, have you seen Who Frame Roger Rabbit? And I tried watching it as a kid.
当你还是个小孩子的时候，这真的很可怕，因为他们对卡通人物非常刻薄。所以我当时想，你知道吗？是的，让我们再试一次。让我们放来看看。所以她打开了电影。然后我立刻就想，哦，这部电影有些非常奇怪的地方。
It's really scary when you're a little kid because they're very mean to the cartoons. So I was like, you know what? Yes, let's give it another try. Let's put it on. So she turns the movie on. And then immediately, I'm like, oh, there's something really weird about this movie.
她说，哦，人类和卡通人物在互动，我说，不，那很好。那对我来说逻辑上是一致的。还有别的东西，就像电影刚开始时真的困扰我。它以一种非常可爱的爵士乐、低沉的蓝调音符开始。然后电影的标题淡入屏幕。这实际上是电影的第一个视觉画面。它是《Who Framed Roger Rabbit》，除了没有问号，它结尾处用的是感叹号。所以不是《Who Framed Roger Rabbit》，而是《Who Framed Roger Rabbit!》。所以那是和我一起看电影的朋友莉兹，她告诉我有一个非常具体
And she's like, oh, that the humans and cartoons are interacting, I'm like, no, that is fine. that is logically consistent to me. There is something else, like right when the movie starts that really bothered me. It starts with a very lovely kind of jazzy, low, blue note. And then the movie's titles fade onto screen. It's literally the first visual of the film. And it's who framed Roger Rabbit, except instead of a question mark, it is phrased with an exclamation point at the end. So not who framed Roger Rabbit, but who framed Roger Rabbit? So that's my friend Liz who I watched the movie with and she told me there's a very specific
的原因。这是因为电影导演罗伯特·泽米吉斯接受了这次采访，他说，好莱坞有一种迷信，如果你在标题末尾加上问号，电影在票房上就会惨败。当你仔细想想，有很多例子支持这一点。所以，比如，《不一样的天空》（What's Eating Gilbert Grape）是一个事实陈述。陈述，好的。《与爱何干》（What's Love Got to Do with It）也是一个陈述。但奇怪的是，这不是每个人都遵循的迷信。所以
reason for that. And it's because the director of the movie, Robert Semeckis, gave this interview where he said, there is a superstition in Hollywood that if you put a question mark at the end of your title, the movie will bomb at the box office. And when you think about it, there's lots of examples that back that up. So like, what's eating Gilbert Grape is a statement of fact. Statement, okay. What's love got to do with it with Tina Turner is also a statement. And what's weird about it though is this is not a superstition that everyone follows. So
原因就在于此。这是因为电影导演罗伯特·泽米吉斯在一次采访中说，好莱坞有一种迷信，如果你的片名以问号结尾，这部电影在票房上就会惨败。当你仔细想想，有很多例子可以证明这一点。比如，《不一样的天空》（What's Eating Gilbert Grape）就是一个陈述事实的标题。陈述，好吧。《与爱何干》（What's Love Got to Do with It）也是一个陈述。但奇怪的是，这并不是每个人都遵循的迷信。所以
there's lots of examples where they don't use the question mark and there's lots of examples where they do. Okay. Say for example, guess who's coming to dinner? I think it came out in 1967. It's a huge, huge hit. It's got Fence or Tracy. It's got Sydney, Pau allier. It's guess who's coming to dinner, no question mark. And I always took that as an example of a movie that, okay, they followed the rule. Contemporaneously, you have who's afraid of Virginia Woolf, which is like Liz Taylor's huge, huge, huge, come back, massive, massive, massive hit.
有很多例子表明他们不使用问号，也有很多例子表明他们使用了。好吧，比如说《猜猜谁来吃晚餐》？我想它是1967年上映的。这是一部非常非常热门的电影。有斯宾塞·屈塞，还有西德尼·波蒂埃。片名是《猜猜谁来吃晚餐》，没有问号。我一直把它当作电影遵循规则的一个例子。与此同时，还有《灵欲春宵》，那是伊丽莎白·泰勒非常非常非常重大的回归之作，是一部非常非常非常热门的电影。
You have, they shoot horses, don't they, starting Jane Fonda. That's got a question mark. That's a huge hit. So, it's not precise. So, you have movies like Guess Who's Coming to Dinner, which do really well, but then you have all these other movies at the same time, which we're also doing well.
还有由简·方达主演的《射马记》。那个片名里有问号。那也是一部大热电影。所以，这并不精确。因此，你既有像《猜猜谁来吃晚餐》这样表现非常出色的电影，同时也有其他表现同样出色的电影。
Right. So, Liz and I were like looking through all these titles in history and trying to figure out like some pattern or some rhyme or reason to why you put in a question mark. And what we noticed is that there's lots of dramas that don't use question marks. So what's even Gilbert Grape, you know, really serious movie, but comedies use them all the time. So, dude, where's my car?
没错。所以，莉兹和我一直在翻阅历史上的所有这些片名，试图找出某种规律、原因或逻辑，来解释为什么要加上问号。我们注意到，有很多剧情片是不使用问号的。比如《不一样的天空》，你知道，那是一部非常严肃的电影，但喜剧片却经常使用问号。比如《猪头，我的车呢？》
That is a question. A brother where art though. That's a pretty goofy film. That is also a question. And Liz's theory about this is it's really, the question mark really sets you up for a certain kind of mood. I would say sort of of zininess or whistfulness.
那是一个问题。《逃狱三王》。那是一部相当滑稽的电影。那也是一个问题。莉兹对此的理论是，问号确实能为你营造出某种特定的情绪。我会说是某种古怪或忧郁的情绪。
It's sort of like one or the other. So you have what about Bob, which is a question mark at the end, because it's kind of like what about Bob? And it makes you feel kind of like cheerful and goofy, like you're waiting for the punchline, you're waiting for the shoot or drop. It's like being told the first half of a joke.
这有点像二选一。所以你有《天才也疯狂》，结尾有一个问号，因为它有点像是在问“天才也疯狂？”。这让你感觉有点愉快和滑稽，就像你在等待笑话的包袱，等待靴子落地。就像是听了一个笑话的前半部分。
So ultimately, there's kind of no rhyme or reason to this. Like there's lots of movies with question marks. There's lots of movies with that question marks. But what Liz explained to me, which is interesting, is it really isn't keeping with how the movie industry makes decisions that one thing does really well, and then they kind of try to guess if that thing is gonna do well.
所以归根结底，这其实没什么逻辑可言。有很多电影片名带有问号，也有很多电影片名没有问号。但莉兹向我解释的一点很有趣，这确实符合电影行业做决策的方式，即如果某件事做得很好，他们就会试图猜测那件事是否会成功。
What was the thing that did it? Again. So she says it's part of this bigger pattern where people are trying to guess things in this industry where success can sometimes feel totally random. You can't fully predict how people are going to act. And so people get very, very into these like, nitty gritty sort of, you know, like,
是什么导致了这种做法？再说一次。所以她说，这是人们试图在这个行业中猜测事物的一大模式的一部分，在这个行业中，成功有时感觉完全是随机的。你无法完全预测人们会如何反应。所以人们变得非常非常沉迷于这些细枝末节，你知道，比如，
oh, people don't like leads with blonde hair this year. That remake flops were never gonna make remakes for like 15 more years. That musical did really well. So now we're gonna do 30 more musicals. I mean, like these kind of superstitions are just trying to put light-nick in a bottle and trying to like,
哦，今年人们不喜欢金发的主角。那部翻拍片失败了，我们未来15年都不会再拍翻拍片了。那部音乐剧表现很好。所以现在我们要再拍30部音乐剧。我的意思是，这些迷信只是试图将闪电装进瓶子里，试图，
apply any kind of rhyme or reason to what is ultimately like such a multi-variant and shifting public mood that will put or not put money in your pocket, that you'll latch onto stuff like question marks in the titles, which is like the equivalent of wearing the same pair of shorts for every NCAA finals game you play in. So ultimately, there's kind of no answer to the mystery, except to say that all creativity and art is a mystery. And what I think I take some kind of delight in is the potential that there's these like sweaty people like in suits like really vexed over whether or not
试图为最终如此多变且不断变化的公众情绪寻找任何逻辑或原因，这些情绪决定了你的口袋里是否会有钱，所以你会抓住像片名中的问号这样的东西，这就像你在每场NCAA决赛中都穿同一条短裤一样。所以归根结底，这个谜题没有答案，只能说所有的创造力和艺术都是一个谜。我感到有些乐趣的是，可能真的有那些穿着西装、汗流浃背的人，非常纠结于是否
a question mark should go next to the title or not. Absolutely. And like, what is this? What is this telling our audience? If we are telling them, dude, where is my car? As a complete sentence. No. Oh, I kind of love it. So I guess I, you know, there's so much of what we do on the show is to think about all the thought that goes into things. And often the result is a beautiful object or a functioning street or a curb cut or whatever. And this is truly like deck chairs on the Titanic. I mean, this is like,
应该在片名旁边加上一个问号。绝对是这样。这到底是什么？这在向我们的观众传达什么？如果我们告诉他们，《猪头，我的车呢？》是一个完整的句子。不。哦，我有点喜欢它。所以我猜，你知道，我们在节目中所做的大部分工作都是在思考投入到事物中的所有想法。通常结果是一个美丽的物体、一条功能性的街道、一个路缘坡道等等。这真的就像泰坦尼克号上的甲板椅。我的意思是，这就像，
this is truly, we don't know how this works. We don't know what it's going on. It's probably means nothing right But we're gonna make all sorts of decisions. It's gonna be a meeting about it It is a whole meeting to decide whether or not dude wears my car is a statement or a question And if that is going to influence whether a teenager is gonna go see that movie. Oh, I love it I love it. I love it. Okay. Well, that's, you know, and mystery unsolved, but I'll now think of it whenever I see a poster
这真的，我们不知道它是如何运作的。我们不知道发生了什么。它可能什么意义都没有，对吧？但我们要做出各种决定。会有一个关于它的会议。这整个会议就是为了决定《猪头，我的车呢？》是一个陈述句还是一个疑问句。如果这会影响青少年是否会去看那部电影。哦，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。好吧，你知道，谜题未解，但我现在每次看到海报时都会想到这一点，
and, you know, like, and someone deciding that this is a declarative statement versus an a query, which is awesome. Cool. Thanks, Chris. Thanks for having me. This episode of 99% of BizBot was produced by Ben Sisto and Chris Barube, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Sri Fusif, music by Swan Rial, with barking from Carrot Rital Rial. RIP Karen, you were a good boy.
而且，你知道，有人决定这是一个陈述句还是一个疑问句，这太棒了。酷。谢谢你，克里斯。谢谢你邀请我。本期《99%无形》由本·西斯托和克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德剪辑，斯里·福西夫混音，斯旺·里亚尔配乐，卡罗特·里塔尔·里亚尔吠叫。安息吧，卡伦，你是个好孩子。
There is a very cool documentary about Ben's investigation called Who Let The Dogs Out and it goes into a bunch of detail we couldn't fit into this episode and it is delightful to watch. It's available now for rent or purchase on all the VOD platforms and as of right now, September 2023, it's streaming on Peacock and Tubi. Special thanks to Brent Hodgie Ali Kelly, and Jozzling Core for providing audio from their movie for this episode. Also thanks to Liz Watson for her story about who frame Roger
有一部关于本调查的非常酷的纪录片，名叫《谁放出了狗》，它深入探讨了我们无法放入本集的许多细节，观看它非常令人愉快。它现在可以在所有VOD平台上租借或购买，截至目前，2023年9月，它正在Peacock和Tubi上播放。特别感谢布伦特·霍奇、阿里·凯利和乔兹林·科尔为本集提供了他们电影的音频。还要感谢莉兹·沃森讲述关于《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》的故事，
Rabbit and to Avery Troufflement, who saw the documentary and insisted we do this story. Kathy, too, is our executive producer, Dillianne Hall, is our senior editor, Cracolsted, is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Jason Dillian, Martin Gonzales, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Bosch Mdahn, Jacob Moltenano Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
以及艾弗里·特鲁夫曼，他看了纪录片并坚持让我们做这个故事。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，迪莉安·霍尔是我们的高级编辑，克拉科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括杰森·迪利安、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、博什·姆丹、雅各布·莫尔特纳诺·梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格和我，罗曼·马斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99 PI at 99pi.org. Okay, Carrot. Light out. Good boy, Carrot. Say, Stitcher. Good. Say, Series XM. Good boy. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们现在是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在99pi.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99%无形》的每一期往期节目。好了，卡罗特。灯灭了。好孩子，卡罗特。说，Stitcher。好。说，Series XM。好孩子。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。